Es ist eine Worst Bird-Produktion.
Immer noch in 2014.
Es ist eine fucking Worst Bird-Produktion. Stefan Tietze, Stefan Tietze, Stefan Tietze. Wow. Stefan Tietze. Finde ich nicht so schlecht.
Finde ich nicht so schlecht.
Schön, dass ihr da seid. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von DPU, dem Podcast Ungeheuer!
Hallo!
Stefan Titzewitz ist heute bei mir, sitzt mir gegenüber, lächelt mich keck an, hallo, vermeidet den Augenkontakt, hallo.
Und Floridin Villnorek guckt mich an, ganz doll, guckt in meine Seele rein, will was sehen, findet wie immer nichts. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu neuen Folge des Podcasts Ungeheures, finde ich gut, gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut. Mit Toni und Caro, die sich alleine in den Wald hier hineingewagt haben, mal gucken, was sie dort finden werden. Es ist Allergie-Saison, das heißt, von mir werdet ihr heute nicht viel mehr hören als Ab und zu zwischendurch, aber da müssen wir durch, denn die Welt stösst mich ab als Fremdkörper. Aber ist es bei dir so, dass du die Allergie überall hast, auch in Großstädten? Birke, Borge, Buche, die drei Bs, die großen Bs, die großen drei Erzfeinde, die es immer noch gibt, aus irgendeinem Grund werden die immer noch gepflanzt, obwohl bekannt ist, dass es Allergene sind. Birke Buche Bimbel, für mich drei Erzfeinde, die Birne ist auch schon skeptisch, ist auch schon auf der Abschlussliste bei mir, aber sie lauern überall. Man läuft durch die Welt, ganz normal, ganz entspannt, plötzlich biegt man um die Ecke, nichts ahnen, Birke! Und dann ist man sofort dem Erdgrund nah. Das Gute an der Birke finde ich ja, dass die noch durch den andersartigen Stamm einem sehr ins Gesicht springt. Richtig, das stimmt. Sie gibt eine Chance, wegzulaufen. Sie gibt so, hey Freundchen, komm nicht zu nah. Sie wirkt wie getarnt, also so Kamouflage, nur für eine falsche Vegetation. Genau, für so eine Schneewelt. Wenn du im Biospiel so Assets aus der Schneewelt nimmst und dann ist der Panda-Bär im Wüstenlevel und ist so, das passt nicht. Der ist wie so, finde den Eisbären im Zoo, ah da ist er, also sehr, sehr schlecht getarnt und so ist die Birke auch. Wir hatten, ich bin auch sehr erleggeschrieg, Birken, richtig, richtig schlimm und Birken auch generell scheiß Bäume, weil die haben zu jedem Zeitpunkt, wo irgendwas draußen in der Natur passiert, meinend Frühling und Herbst, wo entweder etwas wächst oder abfällt, haben die so ganz schlimme, nervige Dinge. Ja. Also meine haben die ja Pollen, extrem, dann haben die diese ekligen kleinen Blätter, die meine Mom im Garten damals in der Heimat zur Weisblut betrieben hat, weil die überall waren und sich so auf den schönen Rollrasen gelegt haben. Ach Gott, ne? Was fällt der Natur eigentlich ein, uns in den Rasen reinzufunken mit ihrem Fortpflanzungswillen? Oh, Pollen, ich will Nachkommen haben, ich will überleben, ich will meine Spezies erhalten. Ja, und dann kommen diese Dinger, die haben ja diese... Haben die diese Würmer, diese Wurms, diese Wurmlies. Die als Kind zerbröseln in der Hand. Richtig, ja. Birkenbrösel. Bis man erfährt, was das ist. Das ist nämlich das Geschlechtsorgan der Birken. Genau, das ist einfach der Pimmel. Der tausendfache Phallus des Birkenphallus, den man in der Hand hat. Alle Birken sind männlich und pimmeln dir direkt in den April rein. Genau, Birkenpenis, wenn du es zerbröselst, hast du das Ejakulat in den Händen verschmiert. Das war dann auch überall, in den Ritzen vom Pool. Das hat sich dann komplett auf den Irrgarten gelegt, ein Hauch von Birken-Ejakulat auf dem Irrgarten. Nee, und ganz schlimm, dann wollten wir den abholzen und dann kam das schwere Geschütz an, zu laut. Der Kamener Morgen wurde zerstört, also der ruhige Kamener Morgen. Durch die Abrissbirne. Durch die Abrissbirne, die geholt wurde und hat sich durch den Weg hinten gebahnt, langsam. Und dann standen plötzlich sehr viele Nachbarn da, um den Jägerzaun verteilt. Und einer war leider von der Stadt. Und das war die Mutter einer Mitschülerin von mir. Und seitdem verband uns so eine Fede, weil ihre Mutter es sozusagen dann uns direkt angeschwärzt hat. Moment, die wollen die Birke entfernen. Einen Naturschutzbaum. Und was man wirklich sagen muss. Täterbaum, muss man aber auch dazu sagen. Ja, Täterbaum, Opferjunge. Und dann aber wurde er trotzdem umgerissen von der Birne oder konnte man sich noch davor werfen und retten? Nee, uns wurde dann rund zwei Quadratmeter geschenkt, sodass wir unseren Zaun, der genau von der Birke durchbrochen wurde, vor die Birne. Also die haben uns eher Grundstück geschenkt damals, als dass sie damit zugesagt hätten, die Birke zu entfernen. Quasi bestochen. Man sagt ja immer, Stefan, was soll man dem schenken, der hat schon alles. Aber jetzt wissen wir es, zwei Quadratmeter sind immer gern gesehen zu Weihnachten. Schenkt mir Grundstück und dann gucken wir weiter. Aber ich meine, es gibt doch keinen Quadratmeter in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, der nicht schon jemandem gehört, oder? Okay, langsam, Flontien, langsam, du bist schon wieder, du bist eins, du bist eins. Wir haben vorher gesprochen, Vorbesprechung, du willst langsam in die Folge rein, jetzt bist du wieder voll reingekrätscht, du hast voll einfach Luft geholt und bam, jeder Quadratmeter der Bundesrepublik Deutschland gehört schon irgendwie. Ja, klar. Ja, aber vielleicht der der Stadt. Ja gut, aber die Stadt gibt dann von sich selbst was ab. Oder nimmt die jemand anderem zwei? Die bricht sich sozusagen den Zacken aus der Krone. Okay, verstehe. Krass, zwei würde ich nehmen. Es gibt wenig, was ich nicht tun würde für zwei Quadratmeter. Weil letzten Endes, mehr brauchst du nicht. Zwei Quadratmeter, mache ich. Weil du kannst dann auch die zwei Quadratmeter nutzen, um die Leiche zu verschachern. Absolut, zweimal ein Meter reicht mir völlig. Alle Leute, die ich umbringen wollen würde, würden da ungefähr reinpassen. Nee, ich nicht. Echt? Wie viele willst du umbringen? Wie lange ist deine Kill Bill Death List? Wie lange ist deine Liste? Nee, nee, ich meine, ich würde nicht reinpassen. Ach so. Ah, okay. Weil? Ach so. Du musst halt meine Arme anlegen und meine Füsschen müssen genau wie auf dem Boden stehend gerade sein. Ja, das ist ein Winkel. Das hatte ich vor. Dass du schön in einem Grab stehst, dass du nicht mal da einen Moment gemütlich kannst. Okay. Meine Liste ist ganz kurz. Nur Smudo, oder was? Nur Smudo. Immer noch, immer wenn ich dir über die Schulter gucke, während du dir hier, du bist ja immer, ich komme ja rein ins Studio und du bist in Schreibarbeiten vertieft, dein Tintenfass steht hier, die Pergamentrollen quillen über über dem Tisch. Und auch wenn wir uns eine Woche dann nicht gesehen haben, rufe ich immer, nicht jetzt, nicht jetzt, nicht jetzt. Ja, und dann schaue ich dir manchmal so spitzbübisch über die Schulter und da steht nur Smudo muss sterben, Smudo muss sterben. In ganz vielen verschiedenen Sprachen, du hast schon Rituale versucht, alles hast du versucht, aber er lebt, der Mann lebt, hoffentlich bis zur Ausstrahlung dieser Folge weiterhin. Jetzt wurden auch so Leichen gefunden, war so eine Schlagzeile und dann haben die jetzt so ein Fahndungsfoto rausgegeben. Vier Leichen, oder was? Weiss ich, möchte ich jetzt nicht genau sagen. Jetzt sagt nicht die Fahnda vier. Nee, aber dann haben die so ein Foto rausgegeben von demjenigen, der die angeblich umgebracht hat. Also dringender Tatverdacht, Täter auf der Flucht. Sieht einfach aus wie ein Mörder. Also der sieht aus wie ein bisschen wie der von No Country for Old Men. Aha, so ein bisschen, wenn man so ein Kinderbrettspiel spielt und da gibt es den Räuber. Genau. Und genau so sieht der auch aus. So genau diese Maske, wo ich mir denke, verhafte einfach direkt die Leute, die diese Maske kaufen. Ja, immer so Performer. Ja, wenn du zum H&M gehst und sagst, Entschuldigung, wo haben sie denn diese schwarzen Masken, die so wirklich nur die Augenpartie erbitten. Zeigen Sie mal ihr Gesicht, haben Sie auch so ein Dreitagebart? Ja, Dreitagebart, ich habe einen grossen Sack auf dem Rücken. Ich frage mich nur, wo kriege ich diese Masken, die wirklich den Grossteil meines Gesichts freilassen, den allergrössten Teil. Wofür brauchen die diese Maske? Wofür ich die brauche? Ach, naja, für ein paar Gartenarbeiten. Also ich fräse da so ein bisschen und dann will man ja nicht, dass was in die Augenpartien rund um die Augen kommt. Ich frage eben meine Kollegin, dann komme ich sofort wieder. Claudia, das ist ein Räuber. Das ist ein klassischer Räuber. Wir müssen auf den Batman-Knopf drücken. Zum Glück haben wir den installieren lassen. Das ist Grimmsing. Wir müssen Commissioner Gordon. Es gibt in dieser Welt leider keine Polizei mehr, sondern es gibt nur noch Batman. In dieser Welt, in dieser comichaften drei Tagebart grosser Sack auf dem Rücken welt. Ja, aber so sah der ein bisschen aus. Das, was ich will, war ein Kind eines Mörders, wo man sagt, why, warum ist der überhaupt vorher auf freiem Fuss gewesen? Ja gut, aber da ist ja natürlich die Frage, wo kommt dieses Bild her? Ist das wieder so ein Phantomzeichner-Ding, wo der Phantomzeichner sagt, wie sah er aus? Drei Tagebart, nehme ich an? Oder macht man das jetzt so mit so Chat-GPT-Bildgenerator, wenn man prompt einfach prompt? Kann natürlich auch sein, dass der Zeuge wird an den Promter gelassen, dann darf der einmal wegprompten und dann hast du das KI-Bild am Ende. Schwierig. Aber das ist halt dann fotorealistisch. Ja, ja, ja. Und irgendwo da draußen gibt es halt jemanden. Also fünf Finger dann, nicht fünf Finger, sondern sechs Finger, weil die KI das nicht hinbekommt. Trottel! Das Trottel-KI. Ich würde sagen, er hat einen relativ langen Hals. Ja, und das KI für den einfach zwei Meter langen Hals. Okay, vielleicht überarbeiten wir das nochmal. Mach den Hals kürzer und dann kein Hals. Und dann einfach direkt Kinn auf, das Kinn stumpf. Der Kopf ist so in der Brust drin. Und dann sagt, nee, das ist viel zu weit. Nee, dann lieber das Erste, wenn man ehrlich ist. Also wenn ich die Wahl zwischen diesen beiden Bildern habe. Und warum ist der Kölner Dom im Hintergrund? Ihr seht aus wie so ein Bionicle, die auch so den Kopf so in der Brust drin haben. Wow! Bionicle, es gab, du musstest dich unterscheiden, wolltest du den Bionicle, der den Kopf in der Brust hatte oder der den Kopf im Gesäss hatte. Moment kurz, Bionicle. Ja, Lego Bionicle. Lego Bionicle. Lego Bionicle, es gab einen, ich glaube, der ist sogar der Feuer-Typ. Weil das Problem, Stefan, Marketing, aus der Marketingperspektive, wir beurteilen das Ganze mal. Pass auf, also, wir launchen jetzt eine neue Produktlinie für Kinder. So, wir haben den Dschungel-Bionicle, wir haben den Eis-Bionicle. Können wir kurz überreden, was ein Bionicle ist? Was ist ein Bionicle? Nur weil du die ersten vier Meetings... Oder wir bringen ein Buch raus. Was ist ein Bionicle? Zum Beispiel, wo drinstehen könnte ja, okay, oder eine Serie so Was zur Hölle ist ein Bionicle? Origin Stories der Bionicles Die fing es an. Waren die immer schon Bionicles? Sind die als Bionicle geboren oder sind es so Vampire, die erst dazu geworden sind? Das sind ja Menschen. Nein. So, und es ist, nein. So, und es gibt natürlich Dschungel, Eis, Erde, Feuer. Hm, welcher ist wohl der beliebteste? Warum wurde das Element Luft ignoriert? Mal wieder. Mal wieder. Dschungel, Eis, Erde, Feuer. Der beliebteste war natürlich Feuer, deswegen. Und der unbeliebteste? Der unbeliebteste war Erde natürlich. Aber um dem entgegenzuwirken, hatte der Feuer-Bionicle seinen Kopf im Schritt. Stimmt das oder denke ich, wie das gerade aus? Eine spannende Gesellschaftskritik, weil wir haben doch, haben wir nicht alle den Kopf zu sehr im Schritt? Flontin? Ja. Flontin? Flontin. Und ja, ich glaube, das war auch, was die Bionicle-Serie aussagen wollte letzten Endes.
Okay, vielleicht habe ich es geträumt. Ich nehme alles zurück. Anscheinend habe ich es geträumt.
Ich erkläre mir kurz mal die Bionicle-Idee.
Bionicle sind quasi so die Repräsentanten von verschiedenen Kontinenten von Gaia.
Also du hast da verschiedene...
Okay, say no more. Und dann, was ich mich gefragt habe, ist es so ein bisschen so ein Power Rangers?
Naja, es sind eher so wie Avatare der Natur Elemente quasi. Also es gibt Tyrann, Barang, Aqamani, Krata Carl und Lika. Krata Carl und Dennis. Es gibt Kata Carl, nicht zum Wechsel mit Kata Carl, dem Disney-Franchise, der dich für Milliarden Dollar verklagen würde. Nein, es ist Krater Karl. Nicht zu wechseln mit eurem Freund, der immer einen über den Durst trinkt, Carter Karl. Ja, genau. Nein, da gibt es tatsächlich viele tolle Videos, weil diese Reihe Bionicles, diese Lego-Spielzeuge haben eine unfassbar komplexe Hintergrundgeschichte, die niemand weiß, die nie kommuniziert wurde, außer in den Bionicle-Spielen und Graphic Novels und dem Theaterstück, das in Berlin uraufgeführt wurde, 1962. Am Maxim-Gorki-Theater. Maxim-Gorki-Theater mit Lars Eidegger in der Hauptrolle. Und ähm... Bionicle... Und da wurde das alles kommuniziert, aber die meisten Kinder haben mit diesen Bionicle-Figuren gespielt, ohne genau zu wissen, was sie sind, nämlich Avatar-Repräsentationen. Du sagst gerade so, dass das Besondere an Bionicle, jetzt muss ich aber ganz ehrlich auch sagen, ich habe mit Bayblades gespielt, ohne genau zu wissen, was es ist, ich habe mit Ju-Ju-Ju-Oh gespielt, ohne genau zu wissen, wie es geht. Richtig. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es jetzt irgendwie das Besondere an Bionicle, am Bionicle-Tum ist, dass man nicht weiß, worum es geht. Man weiss nur auch nicht, was sie sind. Das stimmt, ich hatte als Kind auch Power Ranger und dachte mir, ich will hier gar keinen Angell. Wie anfangen, Flank zu stellen. Es gab verschiedene, manche waren auch Autos oder Dinos, okay? So, bei Bionicles habe ich aber auch als Kind schon gemerkt, oh, ich habe irgendwie den Anfängerkurs nicht mitgemacht. So wie bei Latein, wo man irgendwann denkt, ich komme nicht mehr mit, der Zug ist abgefahren. So war es bei Bionicle auch. Latein ist ja so lächerlich. Und da bin ich nicht mehr mitbekommen. Ich weiß nur, dass einer, ich glaube der Grüne, hatte ein Lego-Technik-Katana, ein Schwert. Und das war natürlich sehr, sehr cool, aber den hatte ich nie. Ganz cool, aber die gab es auch in so einer Box. Die sehe ich ja auch gerade. Das ist so ein Eimer, es sieht aus wie so ein, man fasst es auch gerne an. Also so ein Plastikgefäss und da drin ist so was drin. Das ist Spritzplastik und das war komplett durchdacht, weil die Boxen waren geil und dann hattest du immer diese Wurfarme, die hatten diese Wurfarme und diese Kreis-Fes und du konntest die Kreisfrisbees wiederum in die Boxen schiessen und dann natürlich konntest du diese Kreisfrisbees, also ich erwähne es, weil es auch nicht kreisförmige Frisbees gibt, dann konntest du diese Kreisfrisbees auch separat kaufen mit verschiedenen Motiven, da wurde auch nochmal viel erklärt mit den Titanen und den Arcanoglyphen, die diese Titanen binden und dann musstest du wieder an verschiedenen Orten in Gaia musstest du diese Arcanoglyphen.
Ja, ich erinnere mich, ich hatte den grünen Bionicle. Das war die Wurzelnäbe, die ich hatte. Dschungel-Bionicle, okay. Das ist ja die Repräsentation der Urkraftdschungel. Also es gibt ja verschiedene Titanen, die an verschiedenen Orten des Kontinents gebunden wurden und deren Kraft jetzt durch die Bionicle sozusagen wieder zum Leben erweckt wird.
Und die Bionicle kämpfen wiederum, diese Titanen zu befreien, die damals mit Akadoplyphen.
Die sind versunken in der Erde, die sind einfach sehr, sehr alt.
Gegen wen kämpft der Dschungelbionicle?
Gegen die Zeit, quasi einfach.
Wie ich?
Gegen die Zeit.
Ich kämpfe auch gegen die Zeit.
Ich bin auf die Fahrt gefahren, meine Haare wurden zurückgeweht und ich dachte, ja, ich kämpmpfe gerade, das ist mein Kampf gegen die Zeit. Das Problem hätte ich nicht, wenn die Zeit stillstehen würde. Ich kämpfe im doppelten Sinne gegen Zeit. Ich bin zu spät an meinem Termin, ich rase mit dem Fahrrad durch Köln. Ich bin zu spät, ich kämpfe gegen die Zeit und meine Hairline ist exposed, im Wind ist meine Hairline exposed. Ich kämpfe im doppelten Sinne gegen die Zeit und alle sehen das, wie ich mit offenem Mund durch Köln fahre. Und deswegen hat dich Bionicle auch so angesprochen als Kind, weil als Kind hast du ja Zeit, betratest du anders. Da kämpfst du auch gegen die Zeit mit, ich will endlich 16 sein, ich will endlich Autofahren, ich will endlich Glücksspiele betreiben. Ja, jetzt muss ich aber sagen, mein Bionicle stand nicht. Er saß auf einer Art Motorradgefährt. Oh, das war die dritte Generation. Da bist du schon in der dritten Generation. Ist da Gaia schon befreit? Nein, Gaia ist generell das Land, das ist neutral. Das steht für den Urkosmos, eigentlich für den Stillstand quasi. Und saugt durch die Gravitation eigentlich alles zu sich im Kern der Stillstands an. Ich google das hier gerade, das stimmt alles nicht. Ich erinnere mich, vielleicht war das auch die erste Generation alles anders. Es ist, ja, aber es war eine spannende Zeit. Also ich habe gerne mit dieser Frisbee geschossen. Ja, und das ist auch so ein Kulturkreis, der sich da als Inspiration nimmt. Also du hast schon erwähnt, Yu-Gi-Oh spielt auf antikes Ägypten an. Natürlich. Dann Asterix. Bay Lakes spielt auf das, ja, im weitesten Sinne. Die mesopotamischen Katakombs der Inseln, Zwerginseln. Inseln, Migration. Genau, die grosse Vokalverschiebung. Richtig. So kann man Kindern spielerisch die Vokalverschiebung beibringen durch Bayblades, die aber, glaube ich, wirklich auch gefährlich waren, die Bayblades. Wir waren ja arm und haben uns Beyblades aus Lego gebaut wiederum und haben die aber teilweise auch so modifiziert, dass es wirkliche Teufelsinstrumente waren, wirklich auch mit Spitzen und dann haben wir teilweise auch uns selbst gegenseitig zerstört. Ja, ich komme auch aus so einem Haushalt, wo man mir versucht hat, Trends, also dieser klassische Satz, wir haben Beyblade zu Hause, also das wurde mir dann immer, das war leider so mein, also es gab zum Beispiel diese Zeit, wo man diese ganz schlimm nach Plastik und Weichmachern riechenden Schnüre hatte, die hießen Scooby-Doo-Bänder. Erinnerst du dich an Scooby-Doo-Armbänder? Vielleicht sind das die Jahre, die uns trennen, aber die musste man so zusammenknoten, hat man sich so Freundschaftsarmbänder oder sowas gemacht, mit so einer verschiedenen Knottechnik wurden die dann, ich weiss, entspann dich, bist gleich wieder abgeholt. Wer sowas hatte, wurde zusammengeschlagen bei mir eigentlich. Ja, die wurden dann, je nachdem wie man die geknotet hat, so viereckig, das war irgendwie befriedigend durch die Farben und wie gesagt, brauchst gar nicht darauf reagieren. Und dann hat mein Vater mir dann so irgendwie von seinem Segeltörn oder so, so Tower, so kleine Tower mitgebracht, weil er meinte, so die gibt's eh, die habe ich eh gehabt, hier macht euch das da mit und ich habe die nicht benutzt und dann war das Hobby auch für mich tot, weil das ist nicht, es funktioniert nicht, also zum Trend gehört die komplette Immersion Und bei Babels war es auch so, dass mir dann so ein Kreisel, so ein Holzkreisel geschenkt wurde, der aber, muss man sagen, so eine massive Metallspitze unten hatte. So richtig massive Metallspitze, der hat gegen jede andere Kuhla aussehen, der Babelskuhl war, so ein holzdrehdriches Kreisel. Der. Der war aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, da waren Rasiermesser-Klingen außen dran. Und Panzerschokolade. Der hat damals gegen die russischen Kreisel gewonnen. Also das lief schon gut. Aber es ist natürlich aus Perspektive der Eltern natürlich schon auch ein bisschen bescheuert, wenn das Kind nach Hause kommt und sagt, ich brauche jetzt Kreisel dringend. Und du denkst, Kreisel, wirklich? Die sind wieder, die haben gerade weggeworfen. Jetzt sind Kreisel cool plötzlich. Ist ja auch ein bisschen verwirrend, aber stimmt schon, ist schwierig. Ich war letztens tatsächlich in einem Spielzeugmuseum, sehr, sehr interessant, Spielzeugmuseum aus den 60ern, 80ern, die ersten Playmobil-Figuren und so, so ganz billig und so. Und es gab ja schon ganz früh auch natürlich Spielzeuge als Alleinstellungsmerkmal von anderen Produkten, wie zum Beispiel Margarine-Figuren. Da gab es so kleine In-Margar Margarinefiguren in der Margarine drin, weil irgendwann gab es mehrere Margarinefirmen, die ein und dasselbe Produkt herstellen. Jede Margarine ist exakt genau gleich. Nämlich? Also anders als jetzt bei Butter oder bei Bier oder so, wo man unterschiedliche Unterschiede haben kann, Margarine ist immer gleich. Ist das so? Es ist exakt identisch. Das ist wie wenn man einfach H2O verkauft. Es ist einfach immer exakt gleich. Aber bei Wasser schmecke ich ja schon Unterschiede. Nee, tust du nicht. Ich schmecke dir Stefan Tietze aus Köln. Schmeckt, dass er Geroldsteiner aus 50 verschiedenen Gewässern herausschmeckt. Ja, das können wir gerne machen. Und auch kommt auf Patreon. Kölner Wasser schmecke ich auch heraus. Das klingt für mich nach einer Patreon-Aktion, dass wir einmal 20 Wasser kaufen und Stefan das durchtestet. Das können wir gerne machen und am Ende wirst du weinen und ganz viele Entschuldigungen finden, wie ich bin erkältet oder die Kohlensauraten mir die Zunge weggebratzelt. Das Wasser war abgelaufen. Das Wasser war abgelaufen, ja. Okay, und dann gab es Marinefiguren, also wie man das kennt. Margarinefiguren, genau, und die waren dann komplett gelb und sahen exakt aus wie Margarine, so dass du die auch einfach essen kannst, aus Versehen, wenn du nicht wusstest, was los ist. Ganz, ganz krude, so die Anfänge von Spielzeug und wo du irgendwie versucht hast, die Kinder zu holen. Aber tatsächlich ein interessantes Thema. Wo wir gerade bei Patreon waren, da hat sich jetzt einiges getan. Ich dachte, wir nutzen mal kurz die Zeit, um euch das zu erklären. Die Verwirrung. Okay, also, viele von euch mussten viele hundert Gigabyte runterladen, das tut uns leid, dass der Feed in gewisser Weise gebrochen ist und ihr viele, auch sage ich mal, nicht jugendfreie Inhalte automatisch über den Feed runtergeladen habt. Da hat der Stefan leider ein paar Knöpfe zu viel gedrückt. Ich habe ein paar Sachen hochgeladen, aber ja. Er kam leider auch viel privates Material mit raus, Urlaubsmaterial, aber das ist unveröffentlicht. Im Film Argo könnt ihr jetzt noch gucken, also auf der .xdvd.rip oder so heisst die Datei, müsst ihr mal gucken, dass ihr das guckt, solange es noch online online ist, jetzt im Podcast-Ufo-Feed. Ja. Nee, wir haben coole Neuigkeiten, denn durch eine kleine Umstellung und eine Erneuerung bei Patreon kann man unsere Folgen, die wir da mal hochladen, die sind ja werbefrei, kommen einen Tag eher. Im Club. Und mit Video. Ihr könnt die Audiofolgen, die werbefreien Audiofolgen jetzt auch bei Spotify hören. Na endlich. Ihr könnt also entweder auf patreon.com slash das Podcast UFO klicken oder auf unsere Website, klickt dann auf Patreon oder ihr könnt bei Spotify uns suchen, den UFO Club, gebt ihr einfach ein, UFO Club, dann seht ihr da die Folgen, das ist der werbefreie Feed, da könnt ihr draufklicken und uns unterstützen, dann habt ihr da bei Spotify den werbefreien Feed und irgendwann, das kann ich schon verraten, wird das Feature freigeschaltet, da arbeiten die Patreons gerade mit Hochdruck dran, dass man auch die Videofolgen als Podcast, dann wird es noch einfacher und übersichtlicher, dann könnt ihr die Videofolgen überall gucken, nicht mehr nur bei Patreon, sondern auch bei Spotify, das wäre total geil, weil Spotify macht ja ja viele Videopodcasts. Viel Spaß beim Hören. Und oder Sehen. Sehen, je nachdem. Ja, nee. Es sind mehrere Sinne involviert. Noch zwei. Wir arbeiten am Fühlen. Wir haben uns ja oft die Frage gestellt, worin sind Menschen eigentlich wirklich gut? Also so im Tierreich. Weil dafür, dass wir so ziemlich krass sind und mit das erfolgreichste Lebewesen. Ja, in den Top 10, würde ich sagen. Ganz klar. Dich gefolgt von den Klassikern Motten. Motte, Garneele, Krabbe. So, wir sind, we're up there. Aber es geht besser. Also nicht aufhören. Ich glaube, wir können noch wirklich weiterarbeiten an uns und jetzt nicht aufhören. Ich habe die Flügel noch nicht aufgegeben. Ich glaube, da geht noch mehr, auch körperlich. Die Evolution kann vielleicht auch da ein bisschen beschleunigt werden. Ich wäre dabei. Ihr seht mich manchmal rumlaufen mit meinem Ultraschallgerät, wo ich teste, was noch nicht auf Ultraschall ist, sondern du hast einfach kontinuierlich schreien. Also wenn das ist mein Rucksack, ich habe eine Fahne. Ich glaube, Kölner wissen sehr genau, wovon du gerade redest. Nur für die Nicht-Kölner. Also ich laufe mit so einem Rucksack, wo oben so eine Fahne dran ist, da wird man nicht im Straßenverkehr mitten, wo man mich sieht, rum. Und da drunter ist so eine, wie man das kennt, so ein Lautsprecher in alle Richtungen und es wird die ganze Zeit geschrien, also so. Das hast du selber aufgenommen, ne? Ja genau, habe ich selber aufgenommen und genau, ich habe so ein Messgerät und je nachdem wo ein Haus zum Beispiel steht, wird das dann anders abgestrahlt und dadurch wird mir mit so einer Brille so sehr schlecht, so 8-Bit-mässig gezeigt.
Gut, wie gesagt, das ist noch Work in Progress, aber wo ich lang gehen kann.
Genau, weil du möchtest die Augen nicht mehr öffnen.
Ja, sorry nochmal an die Familie, die dabei zu Schaden gekommen ist. Die haben mich nicht gesehen auf ihrem Ende im Lastenfahrrad.
Richtig, das tut uns sehr leid an die kleine Claudia und den kleinen Bibo. Der Hund. Vielleicht ist es aber auch schon irgendwann reingebaut. Vielleicht wäre es natürlich einfacher, wenn man das direkt einbauen könnte, aber ich glaube, da ist noch auf jeden Fall Platz nach vorne. Wir haben uns jedenfalls gefragt, sind wir die, die am besten sehen können? Nein. Adler, Habicht. Genau. Sind wir die, die am besten riechen können? Nein. Auf gar keinen Fall Hund. Pferd. Weisst du, worin wir die besten sind, habe ich jetzt erfahren? Im lange Laufen. Ja, wir sind die besten im lange Strecken zurücklegen. Rennen, joggen. Das hat mich unglaublich schockiert und aus der Bahn geworfen, weil man denkt ja sofort an Pferde. Ja, ja, ja. Man denkt ja wirklich sofort an Pferde. Oder Gänse, Weitflieger oder so, da sind die auch normal. Die können halt dann fliegen. Jetzt schau mich nicht so an, ich will dir nicht das eine nehmen. Ist ja gut laufen, ist ja gut laufen, hat ja auch Vorteile gegenüber fliegen. Aber ich denke mir natürlich, wenn ich sowas höre, auch, okay, wow, wie unfassbar unterfordert ist mein Körper. Ja, genau. Also was könnte ich schaffen? Ich könnte kilometerweise, zehn Kilometer, zwanzig Kilometer könnte ich am Stück laufen und ich laufe gerade mal vom Ende der Treppe bis zur Haustüre und zurück und dann setze ich mich kurz hin. Und das ist das Maximum. Und mehr ist nicht drin und ich glaube, mein Körper, das ist einfach wirklich wie so ein Gepard, der einfach so eine riesige Glocke hinter sich herzieht und einfach nichts leisten kann von dem, was er eigentlich könnte. Was ist die längste Strecke, die du je am Stück gelaufen bist? Tja, das muss ja dann ja Kolumbien gewesen sein, als ich den Dschungel bereist habe. Um die Bionicles. Bist du nicht mal von Dortmund nach Essen gelaufen? Auf den Spuren der Bionicles bin ich ja in den peruanischen, kolumbianischen Dschungel reingerannt. Ja. Das war die längste Strecke zurück aber. Ach so, okay. Du bist mit der Gondel hingefahren. Nee, aber das ist ja so dumm, weil man drei Tage hin, einen Tag zurück ist. Den gleichen fucking Weg. Das ist bitter. Ja, das ist auch so antiklimatisch. Man kennt das ja. Und du kommst zurück. Das Ziel ist ja wahnsinnig motivierend. Von Dortmund nach Essen gelaufen? Nein. Aber es muss mehr geben. Also sorry, ich glaube, damit dürfen wir als Menschheit nicht stehen bleiben. Was ist denn mit Gedächtnis? Also hat nicht, also allein an Bit-Byte-Infektionen. Da gibt es doch so Seekühe oder so, die einen sehen. Da gibt es leider noch diese zwei, drei unfassbar schlauen Seekühe, aber sobald die tot sind. Gedächtnis, Gedächtnis. Ja, aber wirklich? Die sehen dich wieder und sagen, du bist das auch. Ja und, ich kann, ich kenne auch. Du, wie du damals diefen, ich hab dir... Quatsch hier! 1979! Ich kenne das Gesicht! Nachtragend hier! Ja mein Gott, da war ich neun! Das waren diese Seeküren mit so krassem Gedächtnis. Ja gut, Moment. Ich meine jetzt aber nicht Dauer des Gedächtnis, sondern Menge, Masse, Masse! Ja. Ein einfach Masse. Ich habe diese Woche ein Video gesehen, das mich motiviert und das mich stark macht. Und zwar, es geht um eine Pianistin. Ja, Gott sei Dank. Ich dachte, du bist ein bisschen so abgerutscht. Bei dem weiss ich nicht, dass es so abrutscht. Dann kommst du an und plötzlich, es haben so viel gesehen von Andrew Tate oder wie der hieß. Nein, nein, nein. Es geht um eine Pianistin. Klavierkonzert, Mozart,
ja, Orchester, alle da.
Orchester fängt an zu spielen.
Es ist oft bei Klavierkonzerten so, dass das Orchester,
also Klavierkonzert bedeutet Orchester mit
Klavier. Und es ist oft so, dass das Orchester
schon ein paar Takte spielt und dann setzt das Klavier
erst ein. Orchester fängt an
und die Pianistin guckt den Dirigenten
an und sagt,
fuck, ich habe mich auf ein anderes Konzert vorbereitet. Und sie hat jetzt noch so eine Minute Zeit, so ein paar Seiten, bis sie einsteigt. Und innerhalb dieses Videoclips sieht man wirklich die gesamte Entwicklung von absoluter Panik, Verzweiflung, fuck, was soll ich machen, hinzu, es gibt jetzt keinen Ausweg, ich muss es probieren. Ich finde, man sieht aber genau, ich kenne das Video auch, man erkennt den Moment, in dem sie checkt, ah, vielleicht komme ich durch. Genau. Weil sie das kennt, es gibt auch, glaube ich, gar nicht so viele Klavierkonzerte, die regelmäßig gespielt werden, also ich glaube, die haben dann auch schon mal viele gespielt. Ja, klar. Das ist eine weltberühmte Pianistin, die hat das alles drauf, aber natürlich bereitet man sich vor. Ja, und du bist ja auch auswendig und so, du hast ja auch dann keine Noten. Ja, und ich finde es so beeindruckend, wie sie diesen Weg schafft, mit reiner Willensstärke diese Panik umzuwandeln in ein Ich pack das, ich krieg das hin und dann will ich diese Ruhekerne ein und sie fängt an und spielt es perfekt bis zum Ende.
Und da dachte ich mir, holy shit, das kann eine fucking Fledermaus nicht.
So sorry, aber da ist der Mensch krass, einfach wie viele Klavierkonzerte hat diese Frau in ihrem Kopf, wie viele Bücher an Notenmaterial hat die komplett drin oder in den Fingern oder wo auch immer das gespeichert ist, aber das kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass irgendeine fucking Seegurke, die den ganzen Tag im Meeresgrund rumliegt, dass die da halbwegs damit konkurrieren könnte. Never ever. Allein an Mengen, an Informationsmasse kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Klar, die Seeku erinnert sich an den Trainer von vor acht Jahren, aber wie viele Menschen hat die in ihrem Leben gesehen? Neun? Ja, aber das ist schon krass. Ja, aber die Pianistin hat ja auch neun Leute, die sie kennt, plus sechs Klavierkonzerte von Mozart. Ja, also ich glaube, der Mensch hat das beste Gedächtnis. Aber jetzt fand ich gerade, du sagst was sehr Entscheidendes.
Wegen der Willenkraft. Ja, du hast nicht gesagt, weil sie so das alles drauf hat und so eine krasse Pianistin ist. Und ich glaube, da ist was dran. Weil angenommen, die hätte vorher, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht war da jemand im Publikum und sie war besonders aufgeregt oder sowas. Nur wenn man jetzt mal, wenn man leicht die Parameter ändert,
wie zum Beispiel,
es war nur halb ausverkauft
oder es war irgendwie der
fünfte Tourstopp oder sowas und
alles ein bisschen egal, leer,
wäre sie dann auch drauf gekommen.
Also weißt du, was ich meine?
Diese geballte Willenskraft
und das muss jetzt funktionieren,
ich glaube, da ist was dran, dass das Dinge auslösen kann. Man sagt ja auch, dass so Eltern beobachtet wurden, die dann, wenn die Familie bedroht war, plötzlich irgendwie ein Auto hochgehoben haben. Fliegen konnten. Genau, fliegen konnten. Ich kenne die Geschichte. Man kenne die Geschichte, wo das Wasser gehen konnte. Das heißt, du meinst jetzt so, das klassische Seepferdchen hat selten solche Druckmomente, wo es über sich hinaus wachsen muss.
Ja, ich glaube, da ist Bewusstsein entscheidend. Weil so maximales Bewusstsein im Jetzt zu sein, sich der eigenen Existenz bewusst zu sein und das Scheitern ist keine Option. Und ich glaube, das Seeferdchen ist zu erstaunlichem fähig in einem Todesjagd, wo es von einer Moräne, einer gemeinen Moräne, 40 cm weit gejagt wird. Ja, ja, ja. Alles in ganz klein klein, aber in der ganzen Existenz in 40 cm. Ja, das stimmt. Kann man die geil essen eigentlich, Moränen, oder? Ich war bei Seefällchen. Ach so, ah gut, das ist eher so snackig mässig, ne? Wie so Onion Rings. Oder so Onion Rings oder so Knusper. Ich meine, es gibt ja diese kleinen Kängurus, diese Chips-Kängurus, die Jumpies, die kleinen, lass mich nicht hängen, die kleinen Jumpies, die kleinen Cracker-Chips-Kängurus, Ungarisch, Kängurus-Ungarisch, lecker, die kleinen Jumpies, das sind die Jumpies. Es gibt ja diese merkwürdige Kategorie von Chips in der kleinen Tüte. Ja. So, und das sind die Sticks, die Ringlies und die Jumpies. Und die Menschheit hat sich geeinigt auf, okay, die grossen Tüten gibt es alles. Es gibt Beeren, es gibt Erdnussflocken, es gibt Chips in allen Sorten, alles. Aber in den kleinen, kompakten Tüten gibt es nur drei. Es gibt die Fritz-Sticks, es gibt die Ringlis und es gibt die Jumpies. Und da ist es alle Haribo-Grossentüten in Klein auch? Oder ist es da ähnlich? Bei Haribo gibt es ja verschiedene Grössen. Da gibt es ja nochmal so die Mittelgrössen und dann die Kleinen. Ja, ich weiß, dass du es weisst. Warum fängst du jetzt da an? Haribo wurde ja in Bonn gegründet. Ja, ich weiß. Ich frage dich ja, ob auch die sich entschieden haben, dass in der kleinen Reisepackung auch nur zum Beispiel die drei Highlights.
Weil ich kann mir schon vorstellen, du machst ja ein neues Fass auf. Hans Riegel, Bonn, die machen ihren Fass auf. Wir können nicht alle das ganze Sortiment. Sehen Sie, wir haben natürlich verschiedene Dichten.
Hans-Rigel!
Na sicher, wir haben Dichten. Würden wir jetzt die gleichen Süssigkeiten in der grossen Tüte anbieten, wenn sie 500 Gramm wiegen? Sie sind wahnsinnig. Sie muss eine kleine Tüte haben. Sie denken zu gross, sie denken zu gross. Sie denken zu klein. Wir versuchen, was wir können, okay? Aber sollen dann die Gummibärchen auch kleiner sein? Das ist für die Entscheidung. Das ist für die Entscheidung. Ja. Boah, ich will nicht in diesem Meeting gewinnen. Die Gummibärchen sind grösser. Grösser? Je kleiner die Packung, desto grösser das Bärchen. Und wir haben eine Packung, wo nur ein einziger Gummibärchen drin ist. Ich muss zurück nach Bonn. Puh, ist verschwunden. Die sowas wie Succession, aber in so einem Süssigkeitenwerk. Ach so, ich dachte, du bist bei Celebrations. Nein. Du meinst Successions. Ja, Successions. Bounty, Mars, Candle, Droy, Roman.
Die, nee, ich rede jetzt gerade von Succession als Serie.
Ja.
Cool, super funny, cool, wir möchten das sehr gern.
Aber natürlich in diesem grossen Medien-Mogul-Setting.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das aber in so einem, weil da wahrscheinlich gibt es ähnliche, geht es um ähnliche Beträge bei
Haribo. Kann gut sein. Habe ich eine
tatsächliche Filmempfehlung für dich, Unfrosted,
der Jerry Seinfeld-Film auf Netflix
über Kellogs. Zum Thema
Kellogs und die Pop-Tarts,
die man in Deutschland gar nicht so kennt, aber
Pop-Tarts, diese kleinen Frühstücks...
Doch, habe ich jetzt bei Rewe entdeckt und heißen Toasties
oder Toasters. Kann man toasten,
ungetoastet aber auch essen und der ist überraschend lustig. Ich fand den richtig lustig, den Film Unfrosted, schau dich den gerne an, Kellogs gegen Pop-Tarts. Pop-Tarts habe ich tatsächlich früher immer gerne gegessen, habe ich in Berlin am Alexanderplatz immer gerne gekauft, da gab es die in verschiedenen Sorten, habe die zu Hause in mich hineingefressen und die waren richtig köstlich, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr lecker. Landesvielfalt ist bei Puff und Empfehlungen. Ja, kann gut sein. Puff und Empfehlungen. Nee, ich meine mit deinem Film. Ach so, Unfrosted. Was ich auch empfehlen kann, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich es empfehlen kann. Es ist eine Empfehlung mit Sternchen. Es ist eigentlich eher eine Warnung, aber manchmal sind Warnungen auch Empfehlungen.
Und zwar in jedem verdammten Supermarkt diese gefärbten, gekochten Eier in der Eierpackung.
Diese Oste-Eier, die sind aber ganzjährig.
Die sind der Teufel. Die sind wirklich der Teufel.
Warum? Ich habe mich so verfressen an denen. Man kauft die und denkt sich, ja gut, esse ich sich ein Ei. Und mein Problem mit Eiern ist, ich weiss nicht, wie viele Eier eine Mahlzeit sind. Also ich weiss nicht, also ich bin wirklich verloren. Wenn du in einem Frühstückslokal bist und du bekommst ein Rührei, Portion Rührei, drei Eier. Drei. Rührei sind drei Eier. So, aber das Spannende ist, die Anzahl der gesellschaftlich akzeptierten Eier ändern sich je nach Zubereitungsart. Richtig, sehr gut. Du kannst nicht drei Ex-Benedict essen. Nee. Und das so hartgekochte Eier, die man so löffelt, wenn man da drei nebeneinander stehen hätte, in drei Eierbechern. Ja, vergiss es. Zu viel. Viel zu viel. Ich esse jeden Tag ein Ei. Der Herr, Sie sollten auch wie Cholesterin achten, der Herr. Ja, was ist Cholesterin? Wie viele Eier sind Eier? Ich habe letztendlich gehört, dass man in so einem Restaurant Frühstücksdiner, man bestellt Scrambled Eggs und sagt, wie viele Eier man möchte. Und ich wäre völlig überfordert, weil manchmal denke ich mir auch so, oh jetzt schön Rührei. Und dann mache ich ein Ei und es ist halt wirklich einfach so ein Bissen. Es ist wie so eine Briefmarke. Und ich denke, das ist gar nichts. Spiegeleier zum Beispiel, da finde ich dann so drei okay, aber kommt doch auf die Eigrösser an, sonst ihr habt zwei. Aber Scrambled Eggs sind drei und Omelettes auch drei. Ich zauber dir mal ein schönes Omelette. Ich bin bei Eiern völlig verlor. Ein richtig schönes Omelette. Weißt du, was mein Problem mit Eiern ist? Ich weiss genau, was euer ganzes Problem ist. Ihr seid draußen. Der Grund für euer Eierversagen ist Temperatur. Ihr macht Eier immer zu heiß. Die Pfannen der Republik sind zu heiß. Wenn du so einen Herd hast mit 0 bis 9. Wir können meine Glossel im Pfalzdorf-Magazin lesen, die Pfannen der Republik sind zu heiß. Okay, Herd 0 bis 9, wo sind wir bei einem Ei? Vier. Vier? Das dauert da lange. Dauer, dauer. Ja, das ist... Ihr habt doch nicht ewig Zeit, Mensch, wenn du ged sein, Mensch. Frühstück sein. Nee, okay, aber gut, wollte ich aber gar nicht sagen. Mein Problem... Das ist vielleicht noch die Kritik, die ich bekomme für meine Falster-Glosse, ist das oft, dass ich am Problem vorbeischreite. Ja, vor allem, dass du den Leuten immer Dinge unterstellst, die gar nicht wahr sind. Ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich alle. Ja. Wie warm sollte mein Ei Das wäre ich im Falle, wie lang das ist. Wie lang ist das Ei? Ich weiß nicht, was du willst. Du fragst dich, gilt die Zeit ab Kochen oder davor? Gilt die, die sagen da vier Minuten, gilt das ab, wenn ich es aus dem Kühlschrank nehme oder ab, wenn ich es in den Topf werfe? Ja, Stefan, genau, das ist mein Problem. Ich verstehe das Problem. Eier im Kühlschrank oder nicht? Nein, ich habe keine Frage. Ich habe eine Problematik. Meine Problematik lautet folgende. Eier sind sowohl Zutat für Gerichte als auch selbst ein Gericht. Oh, weiß ich nicht. Und das verwirrt mich. Eier sind kein Gericht. Du hast ja gerade gesagt, Spiegelei oder so. Spiegelei kannst du Rührei oder so. Nein, nur in Kombination. Kann man sich reinschmatzen. Nein, nein, nein. Kann man sich reinschmatzen. Kein Ernst. Brauchst du ein bisschen Salz dran, dann ist das in Ordnung. Klar, so ein Frühstücksei. Aber das ist so mein Problem, weil du isst nicht Mehl einfach. Du isst auch nicht Zucker. Du isst halt Gerichte, aber bei Eiern, weil wenn ich mir Pfannkuchen mache, dann weiss ich, ah, okay, Pfannkuchen für eine Person, zwei Eier. Und jetzt esse ich eine Mahlzeit mit Eiern und plötzlich bin ich mit drei zufrieden als Rühreihe? Obwohl doch beim Pfannkuchen zwei Eier plus Mehl plus Milch plus alles. Plus Zucker, plus Zucker, plus Zucker. Ja, plus Zucker, plus Butter, plus Butter. Ich meine, und plötzlich bin ich mit 150 Prozent der Eier zufrieden, obwohl alles andere fehlt, verstehe ich nicht. Und das ist mein Problem mit Eiern, weil vielleicht ist es sogar ein Fehler, Eier als solche zu essen. Vielleicht sollten Eier nur Zutat sein in Buletten, in Pfannkuchen, in Eierkuchen, in Carbonara. Ich finde für jemanden, der mal Schinken mit Nutella gegessen hat, siehst du da eine erstaunliche Was könnte die Gesellschaft von mir denken Grenze. Aber das kenne ich auch, als jemand, der mit dem Löffel abends manchmal da sitzt, die Vorhänge zumacht, um dann Nutella aus dem Glas zu essen, denke ich mir bei jedem Eigericht auch, boah, vier Eier, wenn das die Mama wüsste, wenn das Muttern wüsste. Ich finde aber auch zum Beispiel, angenommen, du trinkst Milch, wüsste ich auch nicht, wie viel ist angemessen, wie viel ist akzeptabel. Weil das normalerweise eine Zutat für andere Sachen ist.
Ich finde Spaghetti Carbonara ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Bei mir für zwei Personen zwei Eier rein.
Und jetzt kommst du mit deinem Rührei drei Eier?
Wo sind die Pasta? Wo sind die Spaghetti hin?
Also das funktioniert für mich überhaupt nicht.
Und Osternzeit ist eine schreckliche Zeit für mich.
Ich liebe Ostern.
Ja, aber diese gekochten Eier. Eier dürfen nicht gekocht verkauft werden.
Weil ein Ei ist ein Aufwand und dann hast du ein Ei am Ende.
Aber wenn du sie gekocht verkaufst und du einfach schon an der Supermarktkasse, bevor du auf dem Parkplatz bist, schon die Schale wegknibbeln kannst und die einfach in einem Stück reinfräsen kannst. Das ist zu viel. Der Mensch ist nicht bereit für diese Menge an Ei. Ich bin auch bei bei diesen prä vorbereiteten Sachen immer so ein bisschen skeptisch, die auf den Supermarkt kommen. Ich habe nämlich jetzt, ich bin ja super faul und dann gab es da in meinem Rewe so vorgeschnibbeltes Knoblauch in so einem kleinen Gefäß. Oh, wie faul willst du sein? Genau, wie faul willst du sein? Eigentlich müsste diese Marke heißen, du faule Sau. Jetzt von du faule Sau. I can't believe how lazy you are.
Ah, wirklich, ja genau.
I can't believe it's not butter.
Das wär's doch eigentlich.
Can't believe how lazy you are.
Du faule Sau, ne geschälte Banane.
Ja, genau.
Einfach so, du fettes Stück Scheisse präsentiert, jetzt ne Banane, ohne Schade.
Richtig.
Aber wie klein war die Knoblauch geschnitten? Schon ganz, wie man es will, also gewürfelt, wie man es will. Geil. Also No-Notes, wirklich genau gewürfelt, wie man es will. Daneben gab es Zwiebeln, geschnitten, wie man es will. Daneben gab es schon so gerupften Salat, also das kennt man ja vielleicht noch, diese Salatpackungen, wo schon vielleicht sogar so ein Salatmix schon so drin ist. Ähm, nee, nee, die gibt es in Reudig, wie wir das immer bei guter Arbeit gegessen haben, in diesem vom Netto. Als ihr euch fragt, wie die Texte entstanden sind. Sehr, sehr viel Reudig-Fertigs-Salat. Wie viel habt ihr gekifft damals bei guter Arbeit? Diese Frage kommt so häufig. Null, es wurden 0,0 Drogen konsumiert. Wir haben diese Fruchtriegel gegessen, dann unsere Trinknahrung und diese Fertigsalate von Netto. Das war die Ernährung ganz, ganz furchtbar. Ja, schlechte Ernährung ist die Antwort. Das gab's und du hast es selber dann gemischt zu Hause, Knoblauch? Ja, so, und dann habe ich nämlich Aglio eulio gemacht. Ich liebe Aglio eulio, liebe ich. Das einzige Gericht, das man betrunken bestellen kann.
Ja, ja. Besser bestellen kann.
Man kriegt, ah, jo, jo, jo. Das ist nüchtern.
Ah, ja, sei wohl der Herr.
Und kann ich gut eigentlich, so, jetzt braucht man dafür Knoblauch, jetzt hatte ich aber nur noch dieses gehäckselte Knoblauch von einer Woche da rumliegen im Kühlschrank und keinen frischen Knoblauch, weil ich den mich geholt habe, weil ich zu faul war.
Klar, weil ich fettes Stück faul war.
Und dann mach mal, habe ich so ein spezielles Rezept gehabt und so und das konnte ich natürlich noch nicht machen, weil ich schon so pre-hexelt war. Und das war dann so eklig und widerlich und ich glaube, da ist noch andere Sachen drin. Also da habe ich dann gedacht, Schmacksverstärker, weil man muss das kochen, das Knoblauch.
Also du machst eigentlich,
die Zehen kochst du mehrere Male auf,
damit die milder werden.
Und dann häckselst du das mit so einem Pürierstab.
Für ein spezielles Rezept jetzt.
Für mein Alloyolio.
Ah ja, okay.
So, das habe ich dann mit diesem pre-häckselten Knoblauch auch gemacht.
Am Ende war das aber, das war so widerlich, weil es hat nach nichts geschmeckt, nur so ein bisschen künstlich nach so einem komischen Öl. Ich weiß nicht, was die da reingemacht haben. Und das ist so dieses, je unverarbeiteter etwas ist, desto besser ist es natürlich auch. Deswegen so diese vorgekochten Eier, ich weiß nicht. Knoblauch und Öl, Alio e Olio. Was ist was? Ist, ja, also Alio. Alio ist Knoblauch und Öl, Aglio e Olio. Was ist was? Also Aglio ist Knoblauch? Ich komme von Agli. Ah, Agli. Und dann Öl heisst auf Italienisch Olio. Olio. Olio. Olio. Olio. Nee, nicht Olio. Und Aglio ist Knoblauch. Und andere? Ich weiß nicht, wo diese Vorselbe Knob herkommt, weil das ist super weird. Ja, vor allem ist es auch einzigartig. Also warum haben wir nicht den Knobapfel oder die Knobbirne oder warum hat sich dieses System nicht fortgesetzt? Wenn du schon sagst, da können wir jetzt, wir haben so viele Knob, da können wir einfach andere Sachen dranhängen, so. Dann hast du Knoblauch, Knubbellauch, wahrscheinlich Knubbelich. Knubbelich, weiblich, Knubbelich, Knubbelich. Wir gehen mal etymologisch rein, was die Herkunft von Mittelhochdeutsch Knobeluch, Spät-Althochdeutsch Knubfloch, Dissimiliert aus Chlobi, eigentlich gespaltener Lauch zu Chloben. Ah, Chloben, ja. Chloben. Weck Chloben. Ich glaube, Knubloch ist so geil, weil es ist so das einzige, eigentlich mit Masturbation, was geil ist und gesund. Ah, verstehe, ja. Aber Senf geht da auch. Es ist geil, es ist geil gesund, aber auch abschreckend ein bisschen. Weil Knoblauch, der Klassiker, Mundgeruch, Date und so, Knoblauch muss man gucken, hat sich Robo auch gegessen und so. Ist es ähnlich wie Senf, eine räudige Sünde, die aber gesünder ist, als man denkt. Und jetzt erklärt bitte nochmal genau, inwiefern Masturbieren gesund ist. Naja, ist es nicht so, dass das... Muss raus, oder was? Ne, muss nicht, aber es beugt, glaube ich, schon gewissen Krankheiten vor, wie Prostatakrebs und sowas. Du redest jetzt aber natürlich in klassischer, stefanischer Ich-Fixierung vom männlichen Masturbieren. Ja. Weibliches Masturbieren? Dabei kenne ich aber wahrscheinlich durch Glückshormonen und so und positiveres. Gut, aber die kriege ich auch durch Jumpies. Das stimmt, aber die machen dich auch so eine ungesunde Ernährung führt auch zu schlechter Laune, Müdigkeit. Also der perfekte Tag wäre Knoblauch, Senf und Masturbation. Ja, nur passt ein bisschen auf mit den. In niedriger Reihenfolge. Nee, nee, weil Turblauch zu hacken, da ist dann oft so ein bisschen so Schärfe dran, da seid ein bisschen vorsichtig. Okay. Kann aber auch ganz, also kann ja auch ganz interessant sein. Also man kann ja auch ein bisschen mal was Abwechslungsreiches mit reinbringen. Diese, es gibt diese No-Fap-Challenges, diese weirden Leute, die sich so ins Internet stellen und so die Willenskraft promoten. No-Not-November. No-Not-November. No-Fab-February. Ja, aber es ist so viel grösser. No-Fab-Männer, ihr seid doch stärker als eure Lazy-Willenskraft. Und dann, ich weiß nicht, dann sind die so cool, aber die reden die ganze Zeit darüber, wie sie es geschafft haben, es nicht zu tun.
Das ist so und irgendwie, dadurch rückt das so sehr in den Fokus, ich weiß nicht, eine ganz komische Art der, eine ganz weirde Fiktion. Ja, vielleicht muss man es auch mal durchziehen, vielleicht muss man es auch mal durchziehen, vielleicht bist du dann erheuchtet. Ja, bist du für Willenskraft und so? Ich bin absolut gegen Willenskraft, Ich habe überhaupt gar keine Willenskraft. Ich habe gerade gesagt,
wie ich mir zwölf gekochte,
gefärbte Eier gekauft habe, mit der Vorstellung, ja gut, esse ich halt jeden Tag
eins und am selben Tag
habe ich noch zehn Eier
gegessen. Weil
was ist Kolesterin genau?
Ich weiß keine Ahnung, was Kolesterin ist. Und ich dachte mir
auch so, ich weiß auch nicht, wie viele Kalorien ein
Ei hat. Also keine Ahnung, könnte 400 sein, könnte 50 sein. Irgendwo dazwischen wird es wahrscheinlich sein. Ich will es gar nicht unbedingt wissen, weil du jetzt gerade so eifrig in die Tassen tippst. Okay, dann hörst du es weg. Ein Ei hat 155 Kalorien. Ich fresse so viel, ich will, ich fresse so viel, ich will. Und deswegen habe ich überhaupt keine Willensstärke. Was schätzt du denn? Ich schätze 150. Ich habe ja gerade gehört, was ich gesagt habe. Was ist es? 155. Fuck! Verdammt nochmal, fünf daneben! Crazy! Aber ich habe überhaupt keine Willensstärke und ich kenne auch die Hälfte der Sachen nicht. Und tatsächlich, mir ist letztens das Schlimmste passiert, was mir an der Kasse passieren kann, weil aus irgendeinem Grund stellt der Supermarkt meines Vertrauens gerade viele alte Leute ein, die noch nicht die Codes von den ganzen Gemüse-Früchten-Sachen kennen.
Und man ist es ja eigentlich so selbstverständlich gewohnt, dass ähnlich wie die Pianistin, dass man erwartet, ah, hallo, guten Tag, Niedriglohnsektor, du kennst einfach sämtliche Früchte, Obst der Welt, plus ein Code, sechsstellig. Bei Dune gibt es diesen Charakter, wo die Augen so nach hinten klappen. Ja, ja, genau. Und er sowieso, wie viel hat das die Spice-Gilde gekostet, hierher zu kommen, war die Reise nötig. Und du guckst ihn an, er hat so einen weirden Strich irgendwo und er sieht es aus wie so ein Genius Weirdo und seine Augenklappen so hoch, dass man nur das Weiss sieht und er sagt, fünfhundert, sieben, weiss, tausend, ne, ne, ne, und genau so möchte ich, dass wenn man dann so seine Steckrübe dahin stellt, dass sie dann die Augen so hochgehen und die dann so einen Fünftel-Encode eingeben. So kurz so ein Blitz so zwischen den Augen und drei, fünf, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, ne? Ich dachte mir, zum Glück weiß ich, was eine fucking Avocado ist, aber wenn es jetzt irgendwas anderes gewesen wäre, ist es eine Frühlingszwiebel oder eine Lauchzwiebel? Und ich würde einfach mein Schwert nehmen und mich selbst erdeuchen an der Stelle und sagen, okay, bis hierhin und nicht weiter. Das war's. Weil die Vorstellung, dass ich was kaufe, ohne zu wissen, was es ist, wäre für mich so peinlich einfach. Ich habe es einfach gekauft, weil ich dachte, es sieht lustig aus.
Generell, die absolut goldene Regel im Einzelhandel, im Supermarkthandel, ist doch, man spricht nicht aus, was passiert.
Wenn man jemanden, also an der Kasse gibt es diesen Bond,
ich möchte nicht angesprochen werden auf meinen Einkauf.
Genauso redet man aber auch als Kunde nicht über seinen Einkauf. Und wenn du jemanden im Supermarkt triffst, den du kennst, man redet nicht, man guckt sich nicht in die Körbe. Nein, genau, wie am Pissoir, es gibt Höflichkeitsregeln, man schaut nicht nach unten. Und wenn mal ein Blick passiert, dann sagt nicht, oh, die grosse Schachtel M&Ms, nein, man bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, also man spricht es nicht an. Und deswegen ist das so ein Codebruch, so ein weirder Kniggeverstoss in dem Moment, wo er dann fragt, was ist denn das hier genau und du sagst, ja, ich weiss nicht. Ich hatte auch, ich habe so Kartoffeln gekauft in so einer Pappbox und dann meinte die Kassierin, da sind aber einige noch grün.
Ja, okay, ihnen ist aber klar, dass das giftig ist. Ja gut, dann wirke Gegenfrage, warum verkaufen sie Gift? Und dann meinte sie, wollen sie das trotzdem kaufen? Ich so, ja, ja, klar, ich will einfach nur weg aus dieser Interaktion. Und die meinte, die müssen das aber dann wegschälen. Und ich so, okay Mama, ich will einfach nur gehen bitte. Das war so unangenehm, einfach dieses Sie kaufen hier offensichtlich Gift, das sie nicht essen können. Ja, okay, ich kaufe es trotzdem. Ich will da nicht darauf angesprochen werden. Danke für den Hinweis und ich habe das auch weggeschält. Und keine Ahnung, was mit Verkauf, Kartoffelgift, was da drin ist. Ich will aber nicht reden. Ich habe neulich, es gibt ja diesen Trend, ich weiß nicht, ob du es mitbekommen hast, wir sind ja, haben oft geredet über Food Innovation, habe ich schon mal das erzählt? Food, ja, Food Innovations. Wir hätten eine eigene Kategorie, glaube ich. Ja, wir haben oft darüber gesprochen. Die Knoblauch ohne diese Partitionen. Jetzt musst du mich unterbrechen, wenn ich es schon mal in der letzten Folge gesagt habe. Aber die Zitronen, die Snack-Zitronen. Oh nein, bitte. Haben wir darüber gesprochen? Die sind klein gezüchtete Zitronen. Die sind wie so eine grosse Olive. Vielleicht ein bisschen grösser, es gibt ja so grosse Oliven. Sagen wir mal, so gross wie diese kleinen Tomaten. Warum fallen mir die... Aha, aber davon die grossen wiederum. Also die grossen Cherry-Tomaten. Stell dir die grösste Cherry-Tomate vor, die du dir auch noch überhaupt vorstellen kannst. So, dafür lohnt sich mal der Puffo-Club. Wie so eine Lego-Figur. Ja, super. Sowas. Wie die Kle... Naja, wie die Normale. Wie die Robits. Es gibt, nee, es gibt, nein, Wie die normalen. Es gibt die kleinen Minifiguren, die hubt raus. Also so eine normale Lego-Mini-Figur im Maßstab. Zitronen, die wurden auf diese Grösse gezüchtet. So, und jetzt kommt's. Die kannst du snacken. Mit Schale? Mit Schale. What? Aber sind die sauer? Die sind perfekt essbar. Du möchtest ja, weil ich liebe Zitronen, aber ich bin immer ein bisschen enttäuscht von Zitronen, weil du musst sie weiterverarbeiten, um sie genießen zu können. Dabei sehen die so fucking lecker aus. Und diese Schale riecht ja auch so geil. Manchmal werden sie in so Cocktails und ballert diese Schale. Super geil. Man will am liebsten reinbeissen. Man hat gelernt, es geht nicht, es ist ungenießbar und es ist zu sauer. Man braucht sehr viel Zucker, um das zu neutralisieren. Diese Frucht wurde jetzt perfektioniert. Kleine Größe, deswegen war die Größe so wichtig, weil du kannst direkt in den Mund stecken. Oder kannst auch noch einmal beherzt so reinbeissen. Die Schale schmeckt zitronig,
aber so ein bisschen
süsser, also so sehr lecker
halt. Was ist denn da?
Und das Fruchtfleisch
schmeckt wie so eine
Zitronenlimo, so eine
richtig leckere Zitronenlimo.
Bist du dir sicher, dass du das nicht geträumt hast?
Ultrageil! So, habe ich
gesehen im Internet, dann habe ich das in meinem Rewe, hatten sie die da. Dann habe ich das genommen und dann musste es genau passieren, was passieren musste. Ich stehe an der Self-Checkout-Kasse und weil das das neue Produkt ist, dieses neuartige Produkt, ging das dann nicht. Dann ging dieser Alarm an. Die wurden sofort die Handschellen von unten schmeltenten so Handschellen auf. Hey, das sind doch eher aus dem viral TikTok-Video, wo sie darüber sprechen, dass man dann Kassen klauen sollte. Das ist mein Scherz. Und dann kam dann so ein Mitarbeiter, der dann dieses Paket in der Hand hat und dann durch den ganzen Laden geschrien hat. Hör mal, was kosten jetzt diese neuen Snack-Zitronen hier? Dieser, hippen, abzock, viel zu teuren Snack-Zitronen, die viel zu viel Müll produzieren, komplett genverändert. Ultra teuer. Ach, teuro? Generell, genverändert ist so negativ konnotiert in meinem Kopf. Aber ist nicht alles geile Gen-Viege, weiß ich nicht. Ja, ja. Naja, also die sind jedenfalls sehr zu empfehlen. Ich mag die sehr, die sind ein bisschen zu teuer. Ich werde mir die sofort holen, sobald ich sie sehe. Aber ultracool. Ich habe diese Woche probiert, auch ganz neu, glaube ich, also uralt natürlich, aber jetzt neu Tamarinden. Absolute Alienfrucht. Also da stand auch auf der Packung Exotische Frucht für Genießer, was wie eine Warnung klingt. Absolut verrückte Frucht. Es sieht aus wie so ein langer brauner Regenwurm und du hast außen eine Schale, dann eine ganz dünne Schicht Fruchtfleisch und dann einen grossen Kern. Und die Kerne sehen so aus wie so schwarze, wie so Käfer irgendwie, so ganz schwarz glänzende Spinnen oder Käfer. Und es ist wirklich so eine Frucht, wo du dir denkst, ah, so sahen früher alle Früchte aus, bevor sie einfach komplett perfekt gezüchtet wurden. Tamarinde. Tamarinde. Es gibt so alte Gemälde von Bananen, wo die auch noch ganz viele Kerne drin hatten und ganz wenig Fruchtfleisch und so. Und man sich denkt, ah, das ist eine vergleichsweise naturbelassende Frucht. So sah je alles aus, bevor man einfach gesagt hat, was soll der Scheiss, warum Kerne, weg damit dem ganzen Zeug. Und Tamarinde, da hat man genau gesehen, super umständlich zu essen, super schwierig, ganz lecker, so ein bisschen aprikosig, nur saurer, aber einfach unmöglich zu essen und einfach komplett, kann man mal ausprobieren. Aber so sah, glaube ich, alles aus, bevor es einfach mundgerecht gezüchtet wurde. Ja, und dann bin ich ja großer Fan von der peruanischen Frucht Cherimoya, die habe ich da zum ersten Mal entdeckt. Generell da, der Fruchtmarkt ist ganz anders, also da gibt es so Sachen, die hat man noch nie gesehen. Und alles irgendwie super weird. Also nichts, weil ich würde sagen, so, ich, ob es so unsere westeuropäische Perspektive ist, aber so was sehr normales, dezentes wie Apfel. Da gibt es die auch in super sauer. Es wird wie ein Standard, es wird wie so ein Anfängerobst. Du fängst an, Obst zu essen, alles mit Apfel. Genau, fangen wir mit dem Apfel an. So, wenn du ein bisschen dich nach rechts bewegst, kommt dann die Birne. Aber die ist auch recht ähnlich.
So, das, und in diesem Gefilde sind wir so ganz klein, in so einem kleinen Räumchen. Und dann haben die so die Kotzfrucht, die nach Erbrochenem schmeckt. Genau, ja. Dann haben die die sauerste Sauerfrucht, die aussieht wie so ein Ei aus Game of Thrones. Und dann haben die eben auch Cherry Moya. Cherry Moya ist so eine,
sieht so grün
abgefahren aus, so eine grüne Kraterlandschaft
und innen drin ist es so ganz weisses
Fruchtfleisch, was so wie
Toffee schmeckt, also so vanillig,
super lecker, so super
süss, fruchtig, aber
so gar nicht zitrusmäßig, sondern so viel
wie weisse Schokolade oder so.
So ein Riesen. Ja, genau.
So härters Riesen.
Ja, aber so richtig so
Vielen Dank. so gar nicht zitrusmäßig, sondern so viel wie weiße Schokolade oder so. So ein Riesen. Ja, genau. So härteres Riesen. Ja, genau, aber so richtig so geweisses, bisschen wie Kokos, aber so ganz super süss lecker. Und das habe ich jetzt zum ersten Mal in Deutschland gesehen. Kommt jetzt übrigens irgendwie anscheinend hierher. Kommt alles hier? Schwappt jetzt rüber endlich mal? Schwappt jetzt hier wahrscheinlich rüber so die Flug-Cherimoyas. Ich glaube, der Name wird sich nicht durchsetzen, Cherry-Moyer wird es nicht... Ne, ja, deswegen der Knobapfel. Knobapfel. Was würdest du sagen, wo ist es am nähesten dran, an welchem anderen Obst, das wir kennen in Deutschland? Ja, Banane von... Die Knobahne, die Knobahne, die Knobahne, zack, haben wir die Knobahne wieder mit dabei, ist alles perfekt drin. Ich dachte mir mir, bei deiner Geschichte mit der grossen Zehe und jetzt bei den Snack-Zitronen, da ist jetzt vor ein paar Jahren so ein, da ist was gelungen. Da tut sich wirklich was. Hat man mal eine Spritze genommen, von einem hat die woanders rein und dann ging irgendwie so was, da muss so ein Durchbruch passiert sein. Ja, ja, klar. Jetzt können wir alles machen. Jetzt können wir Riesenäpfel, jetzt können wir so Melonen große Äpfel züchten. Vor allem, als du gesagt hast, kleine Zitrone, irgendwie so groß wie ein Lego-Männchen, wie eine Actionfigur, wie so ein Schokobon. Nee, größer als Schokobon. Da habe ich direkt an Futurama gedacht, wo ja Fry bekommt so einen Baum geschenkt, mit allen Obstsachen, aber ganz klein. Wie so Tropifrutti-Grösse. Wo so eine Banane, die so klein wie snackig ist und du konntest es wegsnacken. Und ich dachte mir als Kind schon, das ist ja so geil. Einfach die in einer anderen Größe zu haben, wäre so gut. Und jetzt geht es genau in die Richtung. Wir leben in Futurama. Diese natürliche Verpackung wegzuessen. Diese Schale, in die will man ja reinbeissen. Das ist ja auch ein Gamechanger bei Kiwi. Sobald du checkst, dass du bei Kiwi einfach die Schale mitisst, ist diese Frucht einfach nochmal komplett anders. Ja, klar, man. Die ist so pelzig. Rein da. Ja, das ist auch ganz geil. Das musst du ein paar machen, aber das ist ganz geil. Und plötzlich denkst du dir, ja klar, bei Kiwi und hin und so, klar, du kannst alles daran essen, da bleibt nichts ruhig. Aber wie, isst du denn in der Straßenbahn so eine Kiwi? Lein da, ja klar, alles rein, schön, einfach. Aber dafür ist die ja zu flüssig innen drin. Nee, nee, nee, du kannst es gut unter Kontrolle halten. Für mich ist es die Beiss- und Saugtechnik. Du musst einmal reinbeissen und bevor du abziehst, saugst du nochmal. Aber im Ernst, dann hast du, dann tropft dann nix, dann sabbelt dann nix, das ist die Beiss- und Saugtechnik. Du musst einmal reinbeissen und bevor du abziehst, saugst du nochmal.
Aber im Ernst, dann tropft da nichts, dann sabbelt da nichts.
Das ist die Beiss- und Saugtechnik, da kommst du gut durch.
Wahnsinn.
Leute, ich hoffe, wir haben euch den Mund wässrig reden können und ihr geht jetzt schön los und holt euch ein paar exotische Früchte.
Bisschen Obst, genießt mal nicht immer hier die Snacks, die Ringelis, die Jumpies, sondern einfach mal schön in der Obst- und Gemüseabteilung sich umgucken. Zum Gemüse sind wir gleich gekommen. Was hast du gerade gesagt? Zur Gemüse kommen wir nächste Woche, da stellen wir euch die neuesten Gemüsetrends vor. Ja, wir hoffen, dass in der Woche was passiert ist. Stephans Obstkorb, ich finde es eine tolle Rubrik. Ja, genau. Stephans Obstkorb. Ja, ich spiele diese Boring-Obst-Rubrik immer, die wir immer unterjubeln willst. Vielen Dank für deine Zeit, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Gerne.
Macht's gut, wir heben ab.
Liebe Grüße wünschen euch eine schöne Woche.